okay so i know who you are but um you
can
just have a conversation how does it
feel to be back on the stage
it feels so good to be back on the stage
because uh you know covet has really hit
everyone especially the entertainment
industry so but it's given me an
opportunity this past year to really
focus and figure out exactly what kind
of show i want to do
i've been writing an album my 63rd album
and it's going to be a show trying to
encompass
six decades of music in 90 minutes
and uh it's going to be a challenge but
it's going to be made i've put together
a crack team of people i mean raj kapoor
is going to be
directing this thing and if anybody
knows anything about raj they're going
to say well you've got the best in the
business
and we can hardly wait to get started
it's a lot of work
but august 31st is not that far away
because that's when we start
and it's nice to be back at harrah's
because interestingly enough back when i
was about six or seven years old
my brothers and i were the first act to
open harrah's tahoe
all these years later i'm back at
harrah's so
literally i'm back home yeah and uh how
does it feel
uh to have without your sister in
your own solo career but also like you
said history here at harris i mean
how important this is how excited are
you about what's it one
sorry uh the fact that you are without
your sister your
your soul career here at harris because
you have history uh how
how do you feel and what are your fans
looking forward to seeing coming up in
august
i spoke with marie last night and and
she was so excited she says i am their
opening night i've got to see this show
it's not going to be a rehash of the
donny marie show that's that was
one thing this is something completely
different
and like i said it's more of the six
decades of my
of my life and what i've gone through
the different music uh genres that i've
recorded
but it's so exciting to be a part of
this and honored that caesars
entertainment
said okay you're one of the first ones
that we're going to announce in a big
way
that uh we're bringing life back to
vegas
now i'm not a doctor i'm not a scientist
but
um with all the news from the vaccines
and all that stuff
mark my word las vegas summer of 2021
is going to be so exciting
because it's going to be a new normal
but it will be back to normal
but uh but also the fact that it's
summer time yeah and hopefully we see
more people
we supposed to see a lot more
distributed but just the culture of
what you're bringing to the las vegas
trip yeah um
what uh what other things can you can
you talk about the show
are we gonna have surprise yes
performers no
no no guest performers that's uh unless
somebody shows up and i said hey get up
here on stage i mean that's always fun
to do that's what vegas is all about at
least
that's what vegas was back when i was a
little kid as
i was growing up if there was a star in
the show bring them up on stage perform
that's fun but the show isn't based on
just surprises um however there's a
segment in the show that's going to
change every night
and this has been my challenge what kind
of music
do i present to the audience because
people i was asked the other day
who comes to a donnie osmond show and i
said well primarily the puppy lovers but
if
my social media has anything to say
about that
it's across the board there's a little
12 year old that i found out that just
absolutely loves this huge fan of
danielle 12 years old
how does she know me she said from i can
see your voice
and the mass singer mulan i'm captain
chang of mulan
all these other things so the
demographics are so wide and varied
so this segment in the show henry i'm
going to
have all 63 albums on this
on the screen and they can pick any
album they want
any track i turn to the band 3 4 and we
do the song
and we'll probably do 20 30 seconds of
the song so we get to a lot of different
types of music and different
demographics
and genres within those 90 minutes
and talk about the atmosphere of the
stage or
the shoulder uh obviously because you
used to get previous plays that are
the design that the the lighting going
to be
ambient mood swing or energetic i was
talking to the
caesar's personnel last night and they
said when you really get it right down
to it
harrah's is our newest property and i
said what do you mean because it's an
older hotel it's just no wait till you
walk through this and i walked through
it last night
they have redone everything they
finished all the rooms redid all the
rooms as of january
the showroom is going to be redesigned
and and updated the technology is going
to be completely different
the sound will absolutely blow you away
the visuals
uh the plans that that we have for this
show
i can hardly wait to present it on stage
yes it's going to be
you know a lot of work to get to that
point but when i hit that stage
with all this technology and all these
this
this professional touches that are going
to go into the show
i can hardly wait to present this show
to the public
uh will you be interacting with fans a
lot more with this
type of style i've got some ideas on how
to interact with my
with my fans who i must say
they are the most loyal fans anybody
could ever have
i've have fans that have been following
me since i was five years old
and uh they're still with me and then of
course new ones as well
who just discovered me you know just
recently
but through social media and you know
you got your pros and cons of social
media i
i actually like it because i can stay in
touch with
with my followers and i listen to him
all the time what do you want to hear
what do you want to do this and this
this and this
i do facebook live and and i stay in
touch with these people
because i remember it's important to me
because i remember a conversation i had
with
elvis presley he said if i could do it
all over again
i'd get closer to my fans because
they're the ones who put me on this
stage
and i recognize that same dynamic in my
life
so through your social media followers
and your friends whether like johnny
they've been asking me all year what's
up next and i've just
kept it a secret because really we
started negotiating
this thing about three months ago and i
just signed the contract saturday
so it's like nothing's really in stone
so i'm not going to talk about something
that's not in stone
but the next big announcement will be my
album
and i'm not sure exactly when that's
going to be done but
i'm almost finished writing it almost
finished producing it
and i love the way it's turned out i
don't want to
over hype anything but it's brand new
music i mean i've
there's people i'm working with they're
in the bruno mars circles i wrote a song
with a lady that wrote with
this uh ed sheeran thinking out loud
beautiful song i brought with her
that caliber of people and i'm finding
the best of the best all over the world
i just did a tracking session in finland
via zoom
i got a mix from my friend from virginia
of course la and i did a piano tracking
session in london not long ago
those are the good things about covet
and the technology that it's really
enhanced
so this album i can hardly wait to
release
just like a teaser of anything from the
album or even from the show
no teasers i'll give it to you when i'm
ready
even with the show i've told you a
little bit about what i want to do
but it's just a morsel of what i'm going
to put in that show
because by and large i want people to
walk out of that
showroom saying i heard what i wanted to
hear i saw what i wanted to see
and no they don't remember the lights or
the visuals or the sound
but they remember the experience i want
people to remember
the donny show as a great experience